The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, before we start with
the prepared questions,
I have another question for you.
It's sort of taking a straw
poll before and after discussing
something.
And the question for
you, I want to ask
you is, what is the
nature of shot noise?
The whole set of
questions will build up
to teach you something
about what is shot noise.
In other words, when
you measure in photons,
you start with coherent
beams, you always
have sort of square root n.
And the question
I want you to ask
is, when we measure square
root n fluctuations,
when we detect n
photons, is this
caused by the nature of
the measurement process--
sort of how we detect
photons-- or is it
an intrinsic quantity
of the quantum fields?
So I just want to get your
intuition, your gut feeling,
with the shot noise-- it's
maybe not black and white,
but if you think it's more
related to the measurement--
Well, let me write it down.
Shot noise.
OK, so the question
is, shot noise,
is it caused by the quantum
measurement process, projection
of whatever you know about it?
Second part, is it a property
of the quantum fields?
For instance, if you
don't make a measurement,
if you run the quantum fields
through a beam splitter,
we can split it.
We can split the shot noise
even before we measure it.
That would mean quantum fields.
And maybe then, third is both.
And the fourth is
none of the above.
So let's just take an opinion.
And I'm not discussing
the answer at this point.
I will come back to that at the
end of those 10 or 15 minutes
and ask you the question again.
So I just want to see what your
intuitive understanding is when
you measure the number
of photons in a laser
beam in an optical field
and you see fluctuations.
Quantum measurement versus
properties of a quantum field.
Quantum measurement
means mainly it
caused the moment you detected.
And quantum fields means
it's there already before,
and it can be,
whatever, modified.
Quantum fields or both.
All right.
Good.
Fine.
Let's now go through
the question.
We first have to make sure
that we use the same definition
and measure things
in the same unit.
We want to talk about
coherent states.
So the first is just
little, quick checks.
Coherent states are
eigenstates of the Hamiltonians
of a or a dagger?
For the easy question, I will
just give you 10 seconds.
All right.
Stop.
Display.
Yes.
OK.
That's good.
Next question.
Which states realize the
minimum quantum uncertainty
with delta p delta q
equals h-bar over 2?
I give you five
different states.
And in order to use
the clicker, you
should just answer how many of
them are minimum uncertainty
states.
Ready, set, go.
So three or two.
Let's just go through them.
The vacuum, definitely.
The coherent state, definitely.
The thermal state,
definitely not.
Now, number states,
they are eigenstates.
But let's just take
a big number state.
It's a big lean in
the quasi-probability.
It has a huge delta
x and a huge delta p.
It's definitely-- it's a
very quantum like state,
very nonclassical.
But it doesn't have
minimum uncertainty.
Final question.
x and p, are those minimum
uncertainty states?
x and p are a
little bit cryptic,
because one is infinite,
the other one is 0.
And infinite times 0
is h-bar over 2, yes.
So it's a minimum uncertainty
state, because we discussed it.
It is the limit of squeezing,
when we perform the limit
that the squeezing
parameter goes to infinity.
You can send me
your lawyer, and I
may have to step back from it.
But the way I present it,
this is one correct answer.
It's a limit of an
infinitely squeezed state.
So if the squeezed vacuum--
which I forgot actually
to ask-- if the squeezed vacuum
is a minimum uncertainty state,
then the x and p state
are the limiting case.
By the way, your clicks
are getting recorded,
and the clicks are responsible
for half of your semester
grade.
This was a joke.
You can actually use
clickers and record them,
but then each student
would have a clicker
with an already set number.
But as you see, you just take
a random clicker out of the box
and put it back in.
So I have no idea what
your clicker number is.
And to use the clicker is solely
for our joint entertainment
here.
OK, next question.
What features are unique
to nonclassical light?
And nonclassical
light means-- well,
we have discussed
nonclassical lights
but their different aspects.
One is that the roots
of the two quadrature
components-- the uncertainty of
the two quadrature components--
the cosine and sine quadrature
components are unequal;
negative cosine probabilities;
a correlation function, which
is smaller than 1; and
sub-Poissonian statistics.
So I've given you four criteria.
How many of those four are
features which we will not
associate with classical light,
only with nonclassical light?
OK.
Stop.
Display.
So there's a wide distribution.
Let's quickly
discuss the answer.
Negative cosine
probabilities, well,
if you use w distribution
and p distribution,
negative probabilities
are always
associated with
nonclassical light.
You can also say
it's the definition
of nonclassical light.
g 2 function of-- maybe, I
should not say smaller or equal
-- smaller than 1 is only
possible for nonclassical
light.
Sub-Poissonian
statistics is also
only possible for
nonclassical light.
Now, the fact that the two
quadrature components are
different, you
can just use some,
and you can choose
classical states
and prepare them, that
you have more certainty
in the sine quadrature than
in the cosine quadrature,
so definitely not.
OK, now, we really
need prominently
to discuss quantum noise and
shot noise, the coherent state.
So just to make sure
that we relate--
I will relate later
everything to photon number.
Because photon
number is intuitive.
You can count, you can feel
the photons fluctuation
of square root n and
immediately tell you Poissonian,
if it's less,
sub-Poisson, all that.
So I want to make sure we are
correctly associating photon
number with coherent states.
So, therefore,
the first question
is if you have a
coherent state, alpha,
and we detect all the
photons with a photodiode
of 100% efficiency,
is the number
of detected photons
alpha or alpha squared?
Yes.
Alpha is, so to
speak, the field.
And alpha squared
is the intensity.
So, therefore, form
now one, I will always
use units for the
photocurrent in such a way
that the photocurrent, or
the integrated photocurrent,
is the number of photons.
So when I say, what is
the current associated
with a coherent state,
it's just alpha squared.
Just one side remark.
If you use a laser
beam, you sort of
have a stream of
photons, but you
have a time constant
in your detector,
and every millisecond
you do a measurement.
And then, what I mean by
alpha or alpha squared
is the number of photons
which arrive during the time
constant.
So that's sort of the mapping.
We all usually talk
about coherent state
in an isolated system.
But if you have a beam, you
just chop the beam into pieces
and associate that with
your coherent state.
OK.
So now, we are talking about the
measurement of coherent beams.
We will have now lots
of coherent beams,
running through beam splitters,
being mixed at beam splitters
and such.
And we will always
characterize the strength
of the coherent beam
by alpha squared.
And that means in photons.
So now, the next
question is-- again,
just to make sure we
are all on the same--
we have the same basis,
what is now the variance?
If I measure the fluctuating
current, I measure the current,
I have a coherent state, and I
repeatedly measure the current,
it will show fluctuations.
And the question is, what is
not the standard deviation
of the current, what
is the variance, which
is the standard
deviation squared?
Yes, the standard
deviation is square root n.
The variance is n.
OK.
Stop.
Hide.
OK, now finally, now we can
have fun with beam splitters.
So, so far, we have
really just repeated
a little bit of definitions
of classical and nonclassical
light at coherent states.
We measured current.
We know now in what units we
need to measure the current.
And we characterized the
fluctuations in variance
not in standard deviation
for the rest of this unit.
But now, we run the coherent
state through a beam splitter.
And we have two photodiodes,
one i1 and one i2.
And we measure the current, i1.
What is the variance now
in the current you measure?
OK.
It is A. It's n/2.
The way how you
think about what it
is, when you split a laser
beam with a beam splitter,
you get two laser beams.
Each is half the intensity.
So therefore, each creates a
photocurrent, which is n/2.
And since one laser beam,
which is a coherent state,
gives two laser beams, which
are two coherent states,
each of them has
a variance which
is equal to the photon number.
And this means, we have
Poissonian statistics.
So we have n/2
photons in each beam.
The standard deviation is
the square root of n/2.
And the variance is n/2.
Ask me, if there
are any questions.
I mean, this is still
the preliminaries.
We are not yet bringing
in squeezed light.
Then, it gets
really interesting.
OK, we will always
refer to that situation.
We have a laser beam.
We split it.
We create-- and that's actually
your homework assignment.
We'll actually show
wonderful operator algebra.
If you split a coherent beam,
you get two coherent beams.
And they are simply
characterized
that the alpha value is
now down by square root 2.
The number is down by 2.
And if the number is down by 2
and you have a coherent beam,
the variance is down by 2.
Poissonian statistics.
OK, next question is we
have a beam splitter.
We have two photodiodes,
i1 and i2, and now
we measure-- it's important
for balanced homodyne
detection-- we can now
take the two currents,
and we can add them or
we can subtract them.
So the question is, if we add
the two currents, what is now
the variance in
the two currents?
Remember, each current
had a variance of n/2.
So now, you are asked, when
you sum the currents of the two
photodetectors, what happens
to the two variances?
Do they sum up?
Do they--?
I don't know.
Do people want
to-- does somebody
want to defend
his or her choice?
What do you think
is the variance?
AUDIENCE: It should be
the answer, you just
measure before
the beam splitter.
PROFESSOR: You said it should be
as if I measure before the beam
splitter, and then it would be
n, because we have n photons.
Well, you can also see if
you put in a mirror here,
and you shine the two beams
on the same photodiode.
And then you would say
you have n photons.
And if there are Poissonian
fluctuations, you would get n.
But there is one thing
you should keep in mind.
Since we have the
beam splitter here--
this is the correct answer.
But I want to point out
one subtlety for you, which
will become important later.
The beam splitter has an
open part with the vacuum.
And so when you said we can
measure before or by sort
of just combining the two
beams with a big photodiode,
we can measure after, that's
now a question for you-- which,
maybe hold the thought
and ask me later,
if it doesn't become clear
with the following question.
Hasn't the vacuum entered here,
and hasn't the vacuum, which
has entered here
added fluctuations?
So if you put in
a beam splitter,
and we mix in the vacuum
with our coherent states,
shouldn't that possibly
mean that if you
use a big photodiode and
measure everything together,
that we measure the
variance we had before.
But isn't that
possibly a contribution
of the vacuum, because we were
opening the door to the vacuum?
Please hold the thought.
OK.
The next thing is now, you can't
have the solution that we take
sort of a big photodiode
and combine the two beams,
because I'm asking
you now is, what
is the variance in i1 minus i2?
So you subtract
the two currents.
So the question is, if
you have technical noise,
the two beams would
be fluctuating,
and you would form i1 minus i2.
All the technical noise
would cancel away.
But what is shot noise?
Is shot noise technical noise?
Is shot noise that every
time you prepare an ensemble,
there is a hiccup, and you
can split it and subtract it?
So now, it's getting
really interesting.
To what extent does a
beam splitter-- does
a split coherent state,
which has shot noise,
and you now perform the
difference of the measurement,
can you get rid of some
of the shot noise or not?
You vote, please.
Yes.
So it doesn't matter
whether we measure
the sum or the difference.
So it seems, we have two beams.
And it seems that the
noise in i1 and i2
is completely uncorrelated.
And whether we perform
the sum or the difference,
it doesn't matter.
As long as you think
about classical states
and coherent states, you can
get away with this notion.
But now I'm going to
add some squeezed light.
And now, it's
getting more subtle.
So we have exactly
the same situation.
We have our beam splitter.
We split our coherent beam into
two beams, exactly as before.
But now, I'm playing
with a vacuum.
I'm playing with the open
part of the beam splitter,
and I put in squeezed vacuum.
And just to be specific,
I've squeezed the vacuum
in such a way that
what is narrow now
is the quadrature component
of the coherent state.
In other words, the coherent
state is cosine omega t.
In sine omega t, we haven't
been put in any photons.
Our coherent state has really
a classical oscillation
in cosine omega t.
And what I have squeezed
here with the vacuum
is the noise in the cosine
omega t quadrature component.
So in other words, the coherent
state and the short axis
of the ellipse are the
same quadrature component,
which means, they
can now interfere.
So the question is
now the following.
We split the beam.
We have n/2 photons here.
We have n/2 photons there.
And what is now the
result for the variance?
I formulated a
condition up there,
which is the strong local
oscillator condition.
You should assume,
if you get confused,
that the local oscillator
is very, very strong.
And if you have any doubts
about some smaller terms,
just crank up the
power and make sure
that it's really the local
oscillator which dominates,
which is the biggest
number in all equations.
OK.
So the reference is
without squeezing,
the noise, or the
variance, in i1 was n/2.
With n/2 photons, Poissonian
statistics was n/2.
The question is now, when
we use squeezed light,
does the variance stay the same?
Does it go up?
Does it go down?
Or does it go to 0?
By the way, at the end
of the clicker question,
if you come to me after
class and honestly declare
you got 100% on all
questions, I buy you a lunch.
OK, you're done?
What have you learned?
It's almost random.
I will give you a little bit
formalism later, but I mean,
let me say one thing.
I had a few discussion
with students after class,
and I came to the
conclusion after last class
that I could teach today about
the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithms'
wonderful applications
of all that,
but I came to the conclusion,
you can go to the Wikipedia
and read about yourself.
Because this is simply
using beam splitters,
homodyne detection.
It's just using kind
of all the tools.
But what I said instead is,
I'd rather spend half the class
today in trying to give you,
with very simple examples,
an intuitive understanding.
I mean, everything
I'm saying you
can do with operator algebra.
But to some extent, I feel
when we learn physics,
we use operators, we use
equations, but in the end,
we want to shape our intuition.
And what I try to sort of
challenge you today is,
what happens to noise?
So what I have to tell you
now is-- OK, got to hide this.
The way you should look
at it very soon, I hope,
is the following, that when
you split the coherent beam,
you also split the noise.
In other words, your
little uncertainty circle
goes down in the amplitude
by square root of 2.
It is split-- the reflection
coefficient of the beam spit
and transmission coefficient
is 1 over square root 2.
But what happens is, you
let in the vacuum here.
And so, the vacuum comes into
the transmission coefficient
of 1 over square root 2.
So what I want to teach you
is that when we think back
to this example and we had
this situation with a vacuum,
yes, it looked to
us that we had n/2--
so this was i1 plus
i2-- we had n/2 photons
and the variance was n/2, it
looked completely Poissonian
as if nothing has happened.
But what you should understand
is, that the beam splitter
has taken out-- in amplitude,
1 over square root 2,
when I square it--
half of the noise out
of the coherent state.
But half of the vacuum
state was added.
And half of the vacuum state
and half of the intrinsic noise
of the coherent state give
you back this circle of unity.
And you can pretty much
neglect all subtleties
of the quantum field.
But now, by messing
up with a vacuum,
by squeezing the vacuum,
half of the shot noise
comes from the beam splitter.
It's a 50-50 beam splitter.
But the other half comes
from the open part.
But if you squeeze it strongly,
it's on the order epsilon.
That means, it
doesn't contribute.
And the correct answer is
now, we have-- just a second.
It is linear or quadratic?
Variance is quadratic.
The correct answer is here,
because this is epsilon;
this is small.
We only get half of the
noise we had before.
We had n/2, and
now, we have n/4.
OK.
Now, we take exactly
the same situation.
So the thought is that you
measure the fluctuation here
and you have only half of them,
because this squeezed vacuum,
you've squeezed out the
noise from the vacuum part.
And since you have a
strong coherent state,
everything which is sine
omega t doesn't matter.
Cosine omega t is homodyned,
everything fluctuation
and cosine omega t.
When we measure, the intensity
is the square of phi,
or it's a dagger a.
And so if you measure
a quadratic quantity
and we have a very
strong local oscillator,
everything is projected
on cosine omega t.
This is why only the
cosine omega t fluctuations
of discrete statement are here.
It's a strong local
oscillator limit.
OK.
Now, I hope you've
learned something.
Next question is now, we
do exactly the same thing,
but now we have
the two currents,
and the question is, what
is the variance in i-plus?
I add the two currents.
What do I get?
And I give you the
same choices as before.
Just as a reminder,
when we did not squeeze,
the variance was n.
So the question is now, has
this squeezing done nothing,
or has it reduced the variance?
What is happening?
The correct answer is C. It's n.
And I will show you-- I owe
you a little bit of math now.
But the way how you should
feel is the following.
The noise of the coherent
oscillator is equally split.
But the amplitude-- I mean,
you can say 50% go through, 50%
go through here.
And if you add the
two currents, you
get back the full noise of
the original coherent state.
You would say what
about the squeezing?
Well, the issue
is the following.
The squeezed light,
the squeezed vacuum,
is reflected with a reflection
coefficient, which is minus 1
over square root of 2.
You know when you have two
beams reflected, by unitarity,
it's necessary that
one has a negative,
the other one has a positive
reflection coefficient.
So therefore, you have
this squeezed vacuum
appears in this arm
with a minus sign
and this arm with a plus sign.
And if you sum up
the two currents,
you lose everything which is
related to the vacuum part.
So when you measure
i1 plus i2, what
came from the vacuum part
entered here with a minus sign,
here with a plus sign.
And therefore, you
[INAUDIBLE] what you've
done at the vacuum part.
This is when I told you
earlier, you measure i1 plus i2,
and we all agreed,
the variance was n.
And I said, well, this
is exactly the same
if you put a photodiode-- big
photodiode-- behind the beam
splitter or before
the beam splitter.
The vacuum has not contributed.
That's what it seems.
But even if you squeeze
the vacuum, it cancels out.
OK.
Now, the obvious
next question-- but I
think I've given
you the answer--
is what happens when we
now measure the difference,
i1 minus i2?
Again, without squeezing,
the variance was n.
So now, we measure i1
minus i2, and what happens?
OK.
The correct answer is this.
Well, when I say 0, it's
always epsilon squared terms
which I neglect.
I just assume strong squeezing.
I mean, I just want to give you
the most conceptional problem.
What happens is the following.
And I will show
you the equation.
The noise of the coherent
state is split equally.
So we have a delta a--
a is the field operator,
or the quadrature operator
here-- and a delta a here.
And therefore, the
original shot noise
is common mode, because the
reflection and transmission
coefficients are the same.
And if you subtract the
current, you completely
get rid of all noise,
which was originally
associated with
your coherent state.
Now, what happens is
the small noise we get,
but now, we have to
consider the vacuum part.
But what comes in on the
same quadrature component
point on the vacuum
tube is strongly split.
And because the beam
splitter has different signs
for reflection and transmission,
the noise is anti-correlated.
And if you take
the difference, you
will actually measure the noise
of the input of the open part
of the beam splitter, which
would mean, in terms of order
epsilon-- I didn't work it out.
I think it's epsilon squared.
But it's a power of epsilon.
So anyway, it seems your
intuition fails here.
So let me try to give you a few
equations which explain that.
In your homework and
in most of the course,
we really want to
work with operators.
We do transformation
of operators and such.
But I've found-- for
shaping my intuition--
I found a simplified
approach very helpful.
And I've posted two
references for you.
One is the article
by Schumacher,
and one are some
older lecture notes,
where I summarize some
results of this article.
And this goes as follows.
When you have a
coherent input, you
can say you have a
deterministic classical field.
And then, you have some noise
in one quadrature component,
which is cosine omega t.
And the i is a reminder
that there's also
noise in sine omega t.
So you can really say
the electric field has
a sharp value,
but then, there is
some fluctuation in the
coefficient of cosine omega t
and a little bit fluctuation in
the coefficient of sine omega
t.
And what is important now is, if
you shine that on a photodiode,
this is sort of the field.
The current is proportional
to the square of it.
You have to be a little
bit careful where
you put complex conjugation,
but it is the square of it.
And now, if we use the strong
local oscillator assumption,
we only take alpha
squared, which
gives us a number of photons.
But then, those
fluctuations are homodyned.
We only take-- we
don't consider that
the square of the fluctuation.
We only homodyne it.
We use, at the cross term,
where we multiply with alpha.
So if I now put in
photon numbers for alpha,
we get n photons.
Yes, OK.
And now, we get some noise.
Well, the noise is
the current squared.
The noise is-- we take the
average of the current squared
and subtract the average
of the current squared.
So if you do that--
this is the current
squared-- the current
squared average,
and the average current
squared takes that away.
So we get this here
as the variance.
And now, I have to tell you that
in the units I'm using here,
this delta a1 squared
for coherent state--
so if I show the
standard circle--
the standard
Heisenberg uncertainty
circle-- this quantity is 1/4.
I've just kept track
of my constant.
So therefore, we obtain in this
picture that the variance is n.
And this is Poissonian
light with a coherent state.
And the fluctuation
squared of the current, n,
this is Poissonian
statistics, square root
in fluctuations of the current.
The variance is n.
But what you should
realize is one thing.
The moment I have a
strong coherent state,
the sign quadrature component
doesn't matter at all.
Because if you multiply
cosine with sine and average,
you get 0.
So we only consider the
quadrature component,
which is given by
the coherent state.
This is a principle of homodyne.
You set your
quadrature component
with your local oscillator.
OK.
But now, I have a beam splitter.
And the way you
can think about it
is, you can get everything
in operator algebra,
but just take my word or
follow the procedure now
that we are saying,
we can always
think about a
quantum field that it
has an average value
and some fluctuations.
And if you pass it through
an optical element or a beam
splitter, we have a
transmission coefficient,
but it multiplies the
mean value of the field.
But it also multiplies the
fluctuations of the field.
So that's why I'm saying the
beam splitter is actually
splitting the
fluctuations of the field.
And therefore, you get reduced
fluctuations in either beam.
But we have to consider
that there may be vacuum,
and the vacuum has
also some fluctuations
and will reflect in or transmit
through parts of the vacuum.
So now, we want to
understand photocurrents.
For photocurrents, we take those
quantities and square them.
So which one should I take?
Well, let me take
the first line.
So this is i1.
So if I calculate now i1, I
obtain t squared alpha squared,
plus the cross product
between the first two terms
is 2 times t alpha
times t delta a1.
And then, I get a second
term from the vacuum,
which is 2tr alpha delta b2.
And let me assume that we have
a balanced beam splitter, 50-50.
So t squared is simply 1/2.
Alpha squared is the
number of photons.
So this term becomes n/2.
t squared is 1/2.
It cancels with the 2.
We are left with alpha.
And this is shot noise.
Here, appears our square root n.
So you can say the
shot noise comes
because we have homodyned
the quantum noise.
The quantum noise, which is the
same for all coherent states,
has now been multiplied
with square root n
through the homodyne process.
OK.
So I lost my line.
That's delta a2.
And then-- and
this is important--
because of the mixing
at the beam splitter,
the quantum noise off the
vacuum gets also homodyned
by a factor of square root n.
So now, I think you see
what I told you before.
The transmitted beam has
half of its noise coming
from the coherent state,
and half of the noise
comes from the vacuum.
So if I would now
take the current,
square it, calculate
the variance,
I would find that I have n/2
photons with a variance of n/2.
But an identical
contribution of the noise
will come from the
original coherent state
and from the vacuum.
So therefore, when
I replace the vacuum
by a strongly squeezed vacuum,
the beam, the current i1,
lost half of its shot noise.
We had n/2 photons
with a noise--
with a variance, which was n/4.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why are the subscripts
on the delta operator of
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Because I should
have dropped them all together,
saying we are only using
the quadrature component
of the local oscillator now.
Everything else is orthogonal
to it and cancels out.
But if you want me to put them
back, they should all be equal.
I compiled this writeup from
different lecture notes, which
one had the cosine, one
had the sine component.
I just made a
[? stitching error. ?]
OK.
So this was i1.
If I would now look at--
let me change the color--
at the current, i2, the only
anything which changes is
that because the quantum
noise is transmitted
with a positive
coefficient, that I
have to put a plus sign here.
And now, you realize the magic.
When you form i1
plus i2, whatever
came through the vacuum part,
or through the open part,
cancels out.
Therefore, when we calculated--
or when I asked you
for the variance
in i1 plus i2, it
was independent, whether
there was squeezing,
whether whatever was
at the vacuum part.
And therefore, it doesn't matter
whether I put my power meter,
measuring both currents--
both beams-- before the beam
splitter or after
the beam splitter.
But-- yes, a question?
AUDIENCE: This
last really depends
on the convention
of where we put
the negative sign in reflection?
Because if I had put
the negative sign here
and a positive there, then
I would have been canceling
my delta a's instead of b's?
[INAUDIBLE] the process?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well, so you should
[INAUDIBLE] conventions here.
It's clear that you
have to be careful.
We're talking about
[? face-sensitive ?] detection.
So what happens
is-- number one is--
there is really
physics associated.
When you have a
beam splitter, one,
let's assume you have
a piece of glass,
which has some coating on it.
One beam is reflected when
it goes from the vacuum
to material interface.
The other one is reflected
from the material
to vacuum interface.
AUDIENCE: So then, it depends
on which face of the beam
that will be put which--?
PROFESSOR: But one thing
is absolutely clear.
The two reflected beams, one
of them has a minus sign.
So therefore, when I do i1 minus
i2, the contribution of the--
AUDIENCE: --If a's will cancel.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
It is clear that
in i1-- OK, yes.
But the question
is whether we have
to perform i1 minus
i2 or i1 plus i2.
Well, I don't know
if it helps you,
but what happens is we have
a propagating laser beam.
If you would simply move your
mirror by half a wavelength,
you get a minus sign.
So eventually, all of the
phases-- the beam splitter
phase, the propagating
phase-- all the phases
have to be controlled.
And in essence, what you do is
you put an experiment together,
you measure some noise, and
then you move your mirror
or you change your phase.
And then, you really figure out
which noise is now subtracting
and which noise is
constructively interfering.
Other questions?
OK.
But the other thing
is now obvious.
When we measure i1
minus i2, everything
related to the coherent
input, to the original noise
of the beam, cancels out.
And what we are
measuring is only
the noise which came in
through the other part.
So this is the reason why, if
you have interesting light you
want to measure it, you
use a local oscillator.
But then, you do i1 minus i2.
And this is what I presented to
you at the end of last class,
is the way how
people have measured
the signature of squeezing.
Any questions?
And finally, I think this is
one of the coolest things.
Now, we want to talk about
the displaced squeezed vacuum.
Now, we put everything together.
Remember, we have
learned by applying
the squeezing operator, how
we can squeeze the vacuum.
And then, with the
displacement operator,
I can move the displaced vacuum,
that there is an expectation
value, alpha, for the field.
So it now looks like a
squeezed coherent state.
So this is now the
state we have generated.
And I explained to
you that such a state
can be generated by using a
beam splitter in the limit where
the transmission
coefficient goes to 1.
So the squeezed vacuum is pretty
much transmitted without loss.
But now, we have a very
strong local oscillator.
Also, the reflection
coefficient goes to 0.
We can just crank up the
power in alpha in such a way
that r alpha squared-- the
number of photons which get
reflected-- is n.
So the limit we are looking at
it is small n and large alpha.
But what we keep constant--
throughout actually
all those questions-- is that
we have n photons in that beam.
And I explained
to you in class--
and I showed it to
you with operators--
that this setup
is really creating
the displeased squeezed vacuum.
OK.
Now, we have one
laser beam, which
has an average value
of the field, alpha.
It has certain properties.
And now, I want to ask you, what
is the variance of this beam?
We measure the
photocurrent of this beam.
We measure-- of course, the
photocurrent is n photons.
But what is this variance?
So the choices are
we have n photons.
Is the variance n?
We learned before, with
the 50-50 beam splitter,
that we were able, by
squeezing the vacuum,
to eliminate half
of the shot noise.
Maybe what I've done
is wrong, and we get 2
and we increase the noise?
Or does the noise
really go to 0,
which means it's on the order
of epsilon, whatever I define
for the squeezing for the short
axis of this squeezed vacuum.
So now, we are not
subtracting currents.
No i1 minus i2.
We have one beam hitting
straight the photodiode.
There are n photons
per unit time.
And the question is, what are
the fluctuations of this beam?
What is the variance?
Well, the correct
answer is this one.
What happens is the following.
In terms of fields--
you should go
through that again
a little bit more
slowly-- but what happens
is the coherent state is
sort of this disk.
But when we make alpha
larger and larger,
the disk of the coherent
state is the same.
But now, we have of a
reflection coefficient,
which goes to 0, such that
the product of r alpha
stays the same.
But that means the
reflected beam,
we have divided the disk by
the reflection coefficient--
multiplied with the
reflection coefficient--
so therefore, the original
noise of the coherent beam
has been completely eliminated
because of the small reflection
coefficient.
So the only noise which is
there, is from the other part.
But we have strongly
squeezed the noise
in this quadrature component.
And therefore, the
noise goes really down
to 0 or to I think it's
epsilon squared when epsilon
is the normalized widths of
the narrow part of the ellipse.
I've written down the
math for you here,
which is the following.
We have a reflection coefficient
for the coherent beam
and the reflection coefficient
for the fluctuating fields.
Whereas, the squeezed
fluctuations,
they are fully transmitted.
And what I'm
completely neglecting
is-- and you'll realize it
already-- the other quadrature
component.
Because the moment I square
it to obtain the current,
I'm only considering
parts, which
are in the right
quadrature component,
that they get enhanced by alpha.
So if I square that and
neglect all terms which do not
get multiplied with
alpha, I get this line.
And now, you see that
this term here-- the one
which had the fluctuations
of the coherent beam--
is what I just said.
r times alpha is n.
So this is n.
It would be the normal variance.
But now, we have
another power of r.
So therefore, delta a1
really got diminished.
I mean, you see that
actually already better
in the previous line.
So therefore, in the limit of
r, in the limit considered,
there is no contribution
from the fluctuations
of the coherent beam.
The only fluctuations
come from the squeezing.
And therefore, the variance
is, well, 0 or epsilon squared.
So you can create a beam, which
has no fluctuations-- or almost
no fluctuation-- in
the photon number
by mixing a strong local
oscillator with a squeeze
vacuum.
And that would mean now,
if you take this beam
and send it through
a cesium cell
and do spectroscopy of cesium,
you have reduced noise,
and you are more sensitive
to obtain, to observe,
a small quantity of cesium.
I've posted it actually--
this is exactly what
I described here, how
the first spectroscopy
with squeezed light was done.
And I've posted the paper
of Jeff Kimble's group
on our website.
So I'm wondering, by going
through these examples,
if I would ask you that the
shot noise, which is square root
n in the fields and
n in the variance,
after looking at the beam
splitter and the modes which
are involved, how would you
now answer this question?
Is the shot noise related
to quantum measurement,
is it related to quantum
fields, both, or none?
That's interpretation
of physics;
I think there is
no right and wrong.
I would actually very
strongly-- my opinion is,
it's B. It's really
the quantum fields.
The quantum fields
which are split.
If the noise were done
in the measurement,
you cannot have constructive
and destructive interference due
to the positive and negative
reflection coefficient.
So for me, the noise, which
is responsible for shot noise,
is a field which
can be split where
you have constructive and
destructive interference
even before the measurement
process takes place.
But this is sort of
my interpretation.
And let me maybe point out why
I think that for those cases,
the quantum measurement
process is not relevant.
Here, we've always talked
about square root n
fluctuations, where n is big.
So the fluctuations of
the coherent field--
all of the fluctuations
we were discussing here--
had many, many photons.
So to some extent that we have
maybe just a single photon,
and we can only get one
click and not two clicks,
doesn't measure it.
That doesn't matter here.
All the fluctuations
we considered
here were fluctuations
in the field, where
many, many photons
were involved.
So, therefore, I think
the quantum character
of the measurement process
does not really show up.
If I would construct
something-- other examples--
where we wouldn't always have
this strong local oscillator,
this strong homodyning.
Then I think we
would find quantum
noise of a single photon,
and then I would say,
we're getting closer, that's
really quantum measurement.
But here, I would say
the short noise related
to a strong local
oscillator-- at least,
I find it easier for go
through those questions
if I think about it as a quantum
field, which can be split,
added up.
Constructive and
destructive interference.
Good.
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, when we're talking
about [INAUDIBLE], can we
actually talk about it
without referring to i,
because that makes me
think of measurements.
PROFESSOR: You mean
i, as the current?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: But we
have to do something.
OK, what happens is
i was nothing else
than the expectation
value of a dagger a.
In other words, whenever we
had a photodiode-- I mean,
we learn how to
transform modes, and i
was synonymous to
performing a measurement,
and the measurement
is a dagger a.
And when we talked
about i squared,
in order to get the noise,
the operator involved
was a a dagger, a a dagger.
I think I will ask you
something about the displaced.
Yeah, it's too nice a problem.
I should ask about the
displaced squeezed vacuum
in the next problem set.
I really want you to calculate,
maybe with a higher order
term-- it's a three-liner-- in
operators, what is the noise?
And in your calculation,
photodiode will not appear.
What will appear is
"Calculate the expectation
value of a dagger a.
If you call it a
measurement process,
it's [? inobservable ?] and
it's an expectation value
of an emission operator.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
understand the [INAUDIBLE]
for a stream of particles,
which [INAUDIBLE]
with a constant
probability per unit time?
[INAUDIBLE] The detector
is also [INAUDIBLE].
I think you also
get the square root.
PROFESSOR: Well, a lot of
classical counting statistics
needs to short noise.
If you have
independent particles
with a certain probability,
then you get short noise.
But I would sort of
press you hard to make
a classical explanation for
the last example I gave you,
where we had a strong
local oscillator.
We reflected it and superimposed
it with squeezed vacuum.
At that point, all the
short noise has disappeared.
So therefore, I would be
hard-pressed to connect it
with the classical probability
of detecting a photon.
Of course, classically
speaking, the empty part
of a beam splitter is
empty, and squeezed
vacuum doesn't
exist classically.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So it might be
kind of a silly question,
but we say we have a
minimum uncertainty
state when delta x delta p is 0.
But a lot of times,
we talk about
the number-phase uncertainty.
So, I'm just curious,
because the coherent state
has the same circle
of-- the area
of the circle is
the same, right?
I know this is
wrong, but can't you
always make the delta
m delta phi uncertainty
very small by having
a very large n?
Delta n stays the same, but
the angular spread always
goes down as you make the circle
farther away from the origin?
PROFESSOR: So you're talking
about an uncertainty relation
we have not discussed.
In the last homework,
you looked at it.
So what happens is if you
have a coherent state,
you would say the phase angle
phi has this uncertainty.
And then there's an
uncertainty relation.
AUDIENCE: Maybe you should
have talked about this problem
yesterday.
I think the uncertainty
and the size of the disc
is constant,
[INAUDIBLE] in alpha.
But alpha is proportional not
to n, but the square root of n.
[INAUDIBLE] an arrow propagation
[INAUDIBLE] square root of n.
If we move the
circle further away,
the uncertainty alpha stays the
same, but the uncertainty of n
goes actually up.
But we don't see
this [INAUDIBLE],
because we only have
alpha, not [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, you
have to be careful.
That's another comment
I wanted to make,
but thanks for
reminding of that.
When we have coherent states,
it looks that the uncertainty
is always the same,
because it's a disk.
But we learned today,
and in the last class
that the uncertainty of the
coherent state when you measure
the photocurrent
is square root n.
What happens is the following:
the uncertainty-- and this is
what I was referring
to-- the uncertainty,
let's say delta a in one
[? quadrature ?] component, is
constant for the coherent
state, independent of n.
But that would mean
what you really
calculate, when you
calculate the photocurrent,
is alpha plus delta
a which is constant.
But then you square it.
In the limit of a
strong coherent state,
you get alpha squared, which
is the number of photons,
plus 2 alpha times delta a.
So the delta a,
which is constant,
gets multiplied with
square root n here.
So therefore when you go
to launch a coherent state,
you increase the
number uncertainty,
but by the same factor, you
reduce the phase uncertainty.
Well, I thought this
would take half an hour.
It took an hour, but I hope
it was time well spent.
So let's get started
on the next unit, which
is fully dedicated
to single photons.
So after learning
about different aspects
of the electromagnetic
field, we now
want to focus on
the purest quantum
states, which are
single photons.
And this unit it is
definitely motivated
by quantum information
processing.
We want to use control
over single photos
to realize interesting devices.
We talk about beam splitters
and phase shifters,
but then we put beam splitters
and phase shifters together
to make Mach-Zehnder
interferometers.
And then eventually
I can show you
how Mach-Zehnder interferometers
with a non-linearity
can be used to
realize quantum gates.
But let me make maybe
one general comment here.
This unit here on single photons
has actually two purposes.
It tries to give you some
fundamentals, which are really
necessary to follow recently
literature in quantum
information science, so
we introduce some concepts
of gates and truth
tables and such.
But for those of
you who are maybe
less interested in quantum
information science,
I have to say that as a more
traditional atomic physicist,
I've never worked in quantum
information science myself.
I started with atomic
molecular spectroscopy,
and advanced from laser
cooling to quantum gases.
I feel that using the
quantum logic formalism
is a very elegant way of
organizing your thoughts.
So I do feel even for the
rest of the world, who is not
doing kind quantum
information process, which
is a pretty big
fraction of AMO science
these days, even
for the rest of us,
to use concepts of quantum
logic and quantum information
is very, very powerful.
So in other words, I
would say right now
every atomic physicist should
have some knowledge in what
happens to beam splitters, what
happens to singular photons
when they're manipulating,
and the way, the approach,
how we formulate it using
concepts of quantum information
processing is
extremely powerful.
Like in quantum
mechanics, you need
to know the Schrodinger
representation
and the Heisenberg
interpretation.
You can't get away with one.
Similarly, for some aspects
of the propagation of quantum
states, you should just use the
language of quantum information
processing.
Just sort of to give you
already an outlook where
I think everything
comes together,
I've taught for 15
years, 20 years,
about decoherence
and master equation.
And I know how to derive it
from general quantum physics,
and I will show you that
later in this course.
But then I learned from
Professor Ike Chuang,
when I co-taught
the course with him,
that he could actually make
a model for decoherence
by just passing light through
many, many beams splitters.
So there is a beam
splitter model
for decoherence, which
is just beautiful.
You can give derive a master
equation by just sending light
through many, many
beams splitters.
So that taught me something,
that actually those
was elementary devices for
quantum information science can
really act as conceptual
models for more complicated,
more general things.
So I've decided now,
over the last few years,
to make quantum
information language
an essential ingredient
of this course.
But I should say over
the last couple of years,
I've de-emphasized some of the
more formal algorithmic things,
but I'm focusing
on the concepts.
And I think some
concepts are really
highlighted by using
quantum information aspects.
So with that
introduction, we want
to talk about single photons.
And I want to introduce for
you the single photon qubit.
Now, [INAUDIBLE] would think, if
you talk about single photons,
you automatically
have one qubit.
0 is no photon.
One is the single photon state.
We make in addition
later on, this
is not the most
robust qubit, because
if, due to unavoidable losses
or limited quantum efficiency,
you have one photon,
and you lose it,
you think the bit
has been flipped.
So you don't want
to really use that,
but we will use, in a
moment, a single photon
in two different quantum states.
And then, if you detect zero,
you know you've lost it.
We will talk about one photon,
which is either here or there.
And this is zero of
our qubit, and this
would be one of our qubit.
But we will come to that later.
I first need the Hilbert
space of zero one
to introduce a few
things, and then we'll
use what we've learned to define
the dual-rail single photon
state.
But for now we don't have
to make this distinction.
The question we
want to answer is
what happens when
those states pass
through optical components.
I want to show you how
beam splitters and phase
shifters can be used-- very
simple optical components--
they can be used to realize
an arbitrary single qubit
operation.
And then we introduce
non-linear interferometers,
and we get two qubit operations.
So let's start out very simple
and talk about phase shifters
and beam splitters.
And this is pretty
much how far we
will get today in this chapter.
Well, if you have a single
photon and time passes on,
the single photon
gets phase shifted.
If you pass it through
a dispersive medium,
it will have
another phase shift.
So this is how phase
shifts can be realized.
But there is one caveat, and
that immediately tells us
we can't get away with just
a single photon in one fiber
and phase shifting it,
because everything phase
shifts a photon.
Time and everything which
is in the beam path.
So whenever we talk about the
phase, we need a reference.
So therefore, we're
immediately drawn
that one mode and one
photon is not enough,
even if you're interested
in one-photon gates,
we need two modes.
Just think about two wave
guides or two optical fibers.
We call them mode A and B.
If you put one photon in--
and this is now the symbol for
a phase shifter, a little box
with the letter
phi-- then we get
a phase shift of the state one.
And the second mode A
acts as a reference mode
to detect the shift
of phase, let's say
by interfering the two photons.
So in general, we
have an input state,
and we obtain an output state,
which has a phase shift.
We'll come back to
phase shifters later.
So we'll have two modes.
The next thing we can do
is we can combine modes,
and this is done
with a beam splitter.
So we've talked
about beam splitters
in the context of
homodyne detection.
We've talked about
beams splitters most
of the first hour with
a clicker question,
and I was mainly referring
to the beam splitter
before in a rather
non-formal way.
If you've a 50:50 beam splitter,
and you have two inputs,
you get a symmetric and
antisymmetric combination
of the two, if it's a
50:50 beam splitter.
What else can you get?
Or, I used the concept of just
reflection and transmission
coefficients.
I think that's all important
to get an intuitive
feel for the beam splitter.
But now I use a more
rigorous approach.
I have a beam splitter,
which is characterized
by an angle theta.
We will later find
out what theta is.
And we have an input mode A
and a second input mode B,
and those modes get mixed now.
We have output modes B prime
and output modes A prime.
And we can use the
Schrodinger picture
and talk about the photon
states in those modes,
but I prefer to use
the Heisenberg picture,
so when I put A, A
prime, B and B prime in,
just think about
annihilation operators which
annihilate photons
in those modes.
So what I postulate
is that this system
is described by the
following Hamiltonian.
And I'm sort of telling
you, this Hamiltonian
describes this beam splitter.
You will say, why and how?
Well, I will tell you what this
Hamiltonian does to the modes,
and then we have the
quantum description
of the beams splitter, and you
will then see in your homework
that this quantum description
of the beam splitter
does exactly what it is expected
to do to coherent states.
It just splits a
laser beam into two,
with a reflection and
transmission coefficient
which are cosine squared
theta and sine squared theta.
And I will also show you that
this beam splitter is doing
the same, splitting
with cosine squared
and sine squared theta
probabilities, a single photon.
So in essence, I give
you the Hamiltonian,
I discuss that the
transfer matrix, which
is built upon this Hamiltonian,
does everything you ever
wanted a beam splitter to do,
and therefore you can say,
this defines the beam splitter.
OK, if you have a
Hamiltonian, that
means after propagating
through the Hamiltonian,
we have the following transfer.
You may be familiar with
putting the unitary time
evolution here, and the
time which has elapsed,
but we are always
using a fixed time
after the light has
transformed the beam splitter.
So you can see the
time t is absorbed
in the definition of
h, the Hamiltonian,
and b is really the unitary
time evolution from [? being ?]
before and [? being ?]
after the beam splitter.
So the transformation,
which transforms the modes
at this beam splitter, has now
the following unitary operator.
And we have modes a,
b, mode one and two,
before the beam splitter.
After the beam
splitter, they have
been transformed to
a prime and b prime.
And we obtain that by
taking the input modes
and doing unitary
time evolution.
You do simply the
operator transformation
for unitary transformation.
So we can now transform
the operators a and b.
I'm not going with you
through the exercise
how you transform an operator.
I think in undergraduate
quantum mechanics classes,
you do the
Baker-Campbell-Hausdorff
formula, how to use with
operators in the exponent.
And if you do with that,
you find-- not surprisingly,
a beam splitter is a linear
element-- that what you get
is a linear
combination of a and b.
So if you don't like me
postulating an operator
and saying, "Believe me,
this is a beam splitter,"
you can reverse engineer.
You can say, this really looks
like the modes, the operators
a b get linearly superposed
with cosine and sine.
This is what a beam splitter
does, is it mixes two modes.
And then you can reverse
engineer and figure out
that it's exactly the
Hamiltonian above which
does it.
So your homework will show
that this happens exactly
for coherent states.
So if you've a coherent
state with alpha,
you get a coherent state with
alpha cosine theta in one arm,
and alpha sine theta
in the other arm,
and you will see that
everything works beautifully.
I have to use one convention
now for a 50:50 beam splitter.
And I use a convention
that I chose theta
to be pi over 2
b and 90 degrees.
And we want to use
symbolic language,
because we want to draw
diagrams of multiple beam
splitters and such.
So this tilted square is the
symbol for beam splitter.
We have input ports a
and b on the left side.
We have output ports, which
are now b prime and a prime.
And for the 50:50 beam
splitter, the modes
are symmetric and
antisymmetric superpositions.
So this is the symbol for
the unitary transformation b.
And since one output port has a
minus sign, it's antisymmetric,
and one is positive.
We usually put a dot there
which distinguishes the two
different ports.
So this is the operator B.
We have already used, for
the unitary transformation,
the operator b dagger.
So for the operator b dagger,
using the equations above,
we have input modes a
b, but what happens now
is for the operator b
dagger, the output modes
are interchanged.
So we have a plus b over
square root a, a minus b
over square root 2, and
therefore the symbol
for b dagger has the dot here.
I just want to warn you
that there are other phase
conventions in the literature
which are equivalent.
But sometimes if you read a
paper and all of the minus
signs appear somewhere
else, well, people
have a different
phase convention.
You can postulate that
you have a beam splitter
without having the i here.
And everything works similarly.
It's just that, for
instance, in this equation,
you get an i here.
So imaginary units
and plus-minus signs
and that busyness are
phase conversations.
If you'd say, hey, but if
you another definition,
don't you have
another beam splitter?
Yes, it is another
beam splitter,
but I can always get it out
of my beam splitter-- which
now is our beam splitter--
by putting a phase
shifter afterwards.
So it doesn't limit the
generality of the discussion
by defining our beam
splitter in this way.
OK, time is over.
Reminder, we have another
class this week on Friday,
and finally, your
graded homework is here.
Have a good afternoon.